you want me to service oh you guys want
to hear my long intro what is your intra
how long could your intro be hey that's
a good intro make fun of my intro all
you want but we're going to drink some
ale okay you go there you go get it out
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Jack Wade and Bob
playing murder hey guys welcome to Gmail
hey guys Lord my scream 777 here welcome
to Jesus sorry
sorry I didn't I didn't do anything
special oh really loud did you eat cuz I
like reformed
no I didn't hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to murder with
Jack waiting Bob hi guys look at jihad
stop it what a perfect low ripple far
just kill me hello everybody my name is
Marla and welcome to murder with Jack
waitin Bob go I don't know what Jack
it's your turn personal or not you just
said okay go go go stranger than this
thing okay go go go
god this [ __ ] oh I see it oh it is gonna
get image it is doing damage to the
thing yeah keep firing you firing me
fire woah woah its role eventually yeah
just keep just do it just keep doing it
for underneath I don't know yes oh
that's the rock trying to try and catch
the mouse yeah sure Russian with my
mouth
I'm working on it
Jack you just observe our crotches from
below it'll be fine yeah but I yeah he's
in way doing do it do it I did it
you should operate the the catapult
uh-huh we should play we should play 500
like we used to play in the schoolyard
where mark mark you know you're the mark
is gonna throw rocks and your goal is to
catch the rock and the last person to
catch a rock sucks what you keep making
with the beam that's fine with me next
that's just like that's just like 500
isn't it it's a it's a it's an America
she's just like this place yeah like the
game already
incoming all right aah aah
oh it hit me in the legs doesn't count
there really may not little coming by
look it's right in castle eventually
this is not as effective as I had hoped
wow I'm almost dead ha ha good job
Wow oh yeah okay so wait to shout aah
holy crap
ok we're good let's actually set the
order all right whoa whoa there
I don't care this is my job to kill
people
no way hi you're gonna die on the way
over there
highways I like you oh well all right
do we want to go in the castle see if
there's anything cool can we go inside
the castle yeah oh yeah we should do
that
yeah probably do we need to best open
the door or something or can we just
walk yeah yet someone operate that
someone operates the crowd Pole honey
let's go up there not it knows go I'm
not it cuz I got the gun so why not it
the doors wide open
oh just just say the doors wide open you
don't know that are you the murderer
trying to get us to go through the door
actually I'm here if you are yeah just
it's just a good place to be a murder
did that hurt your legs breaking ow only
a little bit of damage oh it's a
goodness Jenna yes what's this bun hair
worse there's a button oh who is dying
hi buddy
uh friend what can you shoot him matter
here whoa whoa oh do we even know do
whoa this is a love ask a penis oh maybe
that guy was like an escort to guide us
out he didn't seem to be very hostile
and the guy with the gun just shot him
dead hey I was told I was told how to
act
Oh how do you get down here oh god here
can you shoot through that rate get a
place I God whoa whoa whoa whoa you
asked me if I could chew through the
grades would you keep whoa no shooting
from oh I'm Way over here
wait this seems like a bad idea this
seems like a cat fit for the guy with
the gun yeah I don't feel comfortable
wait I'm not feel comfortable most about
we're all for everyone I get away get
away from me Oh guys these latter
doesn't work see we're all stuck down
here oh no no wait wait someone someone
let me get on their head oh wait if you
don't shoot me I will I want you to wait
just go
situation yeah you're not coming up here
this is my area
all right so so how do I pick now this
is a quite the situation these guys they
can't wait
I'm Miko so I think I'm Orange I'm
purple tengo Pacifica we should drop
your gun okay so what do we do to
convince you that we're not lethal I
don't know I've never been in such a
such a good position before yeah at yeah
yeah how about that I like fun and games
if you have the knife pull it out I'll
shoot one of the bystanders and then you
can Duke it out with the with the
remaining by shaving huh is that is that
the point of this game because in this
case that means I'm gonna die right away
the knife awesome your character model
is shifty eyes mark really
maybe this